j'ai quelques doutes sur l'efficacité
d'un tel discours
dans un moment quand même qui est somme
toute graves et pour lequel nous
attendons des informations très
concrètes pour l'aspect territorial en
fait du déconfinement département par
département
il a fait référence à ce qui avait déjà
été annoncé par le président de la
république à savoir le binôme si je puis
dire préfet maire donc c'est quelque
chose qui va de toute façon dans le bon
sens mais il n'ya rien nouveau sur le
volet des masques obligatoire là était
clair pour dire que pour les enfants ce
n'était pas appropriée il a évoqué pour
les collégiens dans le cas où certains
ne pourrait pas sans fournir il faudra
que on leur en fournit ce là où il me
manque mois des informations prononcé
pleinement sur ces mesures là c'est que
qu'il est fourni dans quelles conditions
et à quel moment et moi ce que je relève
en réalité sur l'ensemble d'ailleurs de
ce qui a été dit c'est que healy a
énormément de choses qui vont incombe
est de plus en plus aux communes